[Music]
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has done
an amazing job of linking up numerous
films and characters in The Fairly
cohesive world but for all the work
Marvel has put into making the story
seem real and fully fleshed out there
are still a few things going on that
have a scratching our heads at least for
now here are 6 MCU mysteries were still
trying to comprehend alternate universes
the introduction of Quicksilver in
Avengers age of Ultron also introduced a
whole bucket of confusion considering a
different version of Quicksilver is also
appearing on Fox's line of x-men films
now we know that in the real world this
is because of licensing shenanigans
between Marvel's parent company Disney
and 20th Century Fox but could there be
deeper implications for these fictional
worlds are there alternate versions of
other heroes I could also crossover
between franchises or is it possible we
could even see a crossover between the
Avengers and the x-men or the Fantastic
Four if they all exist in the same
multiverse it's possible they could
interact in the same way two TV versions
of flash and Supergirl do let's not
forget to marvel worked out a deal to
share spider-man with Sony and Fox
negotiated a character rights trade with
Marvel shortly afterward if the x-men
and Avengers could actually crossover
well that would be an awesome
cliffhanger to end Avengers infinity war
as lantus at the end of Iron Man 2 Tony
Stark meets with Nick Fury at a shield
outpost in the background as a map that
has certain areas margins points of
interest including a spot in New Mexico
for Thor makanda in Africa for the black
panther and then a random spot in the
middle of the ocean this seemed to be a
pretty obvious reference for Atlantis
the underwater Kingdom ruled by one of
Marvel's oldest heroes Prince Namor the
Submariner but so far while all the
other teasers hidden in that scene have
played out on screen there has been no
sign of Namor or Atlantis so does
Atlantis exist in the MCU is it hanging
with the Fantastic Four over at Fox or
is there some other secret beneath the
waves only time will tell the red skulls
fate in Captain America the First
Avenger the Red Skull powers his weapons
using the tesseract which is an infinity
stone that acts as a doorway to another
world during his final fight of Captain
America the Red Skull grabs the
tesseract and vanishes he's never been
heard from again so what happened to him
we know from Thor that the tesseract
connects to the nine realms through the
world tray and when Loki entered the
world tree he survived we also know from
Avengers
the alien bad guys can also be reached
through the tesseracts portal it's the
Red Skull working with fanos did he end
up lost somewhere in Asgard or did the
tesseract send him somewhere else hmm
that's my confused noise what happened
in Budapest Black Widow and Hawkeye from
the Avengers have one of the tightest
bonds on the MCU forged in part through
a traumatic shared experience on a
mission in Budapest you will now
remember Budapest very differently but
what exactly happened in Budapest
we know from Captain America Winter
Soldier that whatever happened there was
major enough that members of the World
Security Council have been briefed on it
if you do this none of your past is
gonna remain hidden that Budapest
another sucker and we know it affected
both Black Widow and Hawkeye four years
afterwards in other words it's a pretty
big deal but exactly how big is
something marvelous yet to reveal who is
the real Mandarin hardcore comic book
fans were over the moon when it was
announced that Tony Stark's archenemy
the Mandarin would be the bad guy in
Iron Man 3 especially since the
character had been teased way back in
the first Iron Man a film with
references to the 10 ranked terrorist
organization so fans were aghast when it
turns out that the Mandarin wasn't all
he was cracked up to be
my name is Trevor Trevor Slattery what
are you what do you do you're a double
right well I mean I gotta study
absolutely no don't hurt the face I'm an
act hole fun backlash was so strong that
Marvel filmed a DVD one shot for the eye
among three DVD where Slattery is
kidnapped by people claiming to be
agents for the real Mandarin you see
there's somebody who wants to meet you
Danah him no you took his name and now
he wants it back
and then that's been it so is there
really a true bad guy called the
Mandarin and will we ever see him on
screen fans are still waiting to find
out why are there two Infinity Gauntlet
in the mid credit scene of Avengers age
of Ultron
Thanos opens a vault and puts on the
Infinity Gauntlet I'm doing my show
which is a little weird because back in
Thor we saw that Odin had the Infinity
Gauntlet safely hidden away in his vault
the explanation well according to Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige there are
two different gloves one for each hand
that kind of makes sense but Marvel
producer Jeremy Latium muddied the
waters when he suggested in an interview
that one of the gauntlets is actually
fake so why is there a fake Infinity
Gauntlet and which one is real the one
fallows has or the one Odin has with
Avengers infinity war fast approaching
this is finally one question fans can
actually expect an answer to sooner
rather than later thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know your love to
click it you know you want to click it